i think uh and um lee correct me if i'm
wrong
that uh chinese interests may be
subverting this country
to uh you know global dominance of some
sort
i i think it's the interest of our elite
yeah that's subverting
this country i mean their ties i mean
i've you know
talked about this i've written about it
a bit and the big problem i think is
is china a strategic threat to the
united states yes definitely but the
bigger strategic threat to the united
states is our elites
who have been selling this country off
piece by piece
betraying this country to the chinese
communist party
for decades now so i'm i'm
believe me i'm not making excuses for
uh for what the chinese communist party
is doing how they're trying to
how they're trying to hurt america but
the biggest problem again is
i think that i think that donald trump
had it right when donald trump said i
can't really pick on g
or their or their leaders they're just
doing what they think is right for their
country
how many of our leaders
national state municipal
how many of our leaders have our
interests at stake
if you look at places like we come back
to new york again is that
is that really uh the way that andrew
cuomo
is governing state of new york the way
that bill de blasio is
is running new york city is that in the
interest of new yorkers very hard to
believe
no yeah no it's right now when they put
all those homeless homeless people and
many of them were like
convicted criminals next year wealthy
apartments all right
people are getting attacked they emptied
out the upper west side right right i
mean i mean the the amount of people who
are moving out of there
and these people were these people in
lots of ways they were the
the vitality the wit and the imagination
of new york people living on the upper
west side
they cleared them out right they cleared
them out by sticking homeless people
and putting home way um halfway halfway
houses up there on the upper wall
i'm pretty sure one of the individuals
like a child uh offender yeah
near a school and so naturally the
wealthy people who were there were the
first to be like i can leave and i will
leave
right and it was almost uh it almost it
seems like it was intentional
target the wealthy who can flee
immediately and they do
yeah it's very interesting so that's
what i mean i think it's it's our
leadership
it's our leadership who's not looking
out for us if you look at what the biden
administration is doing you truly have
to wonder i mean i'll just i'll mention
again
the first day you put that much energy
the excel
you know closing down the the pipeline
why why is that so
why was that so vital the number of jobs
the number of jobs that that costs and
will cost them you just look at a number
of different policies
both foreign and domestic was it really
that important do we need to be
underwriting
hamas's war in the middle east by
sending
5.5 million dollars for reconstruction
in gaza i'm not sure did anyone vote for
that who voted for these things people
voted for biden
yeah we are not a democracy we're a
representative constitutional republic
and so in this regard there is a
challenge
and that the politicians lie i mean in
this regard
it's also this is what you get when you
elect someone
not because of their policies but
because you don't like the other guy
and it's the best example of it so you
know very often we've had the two-party
system where it's like oh man mccain's
so bad i gotta vote for obama obama's so
bad i gotta go for mccain
yeah but this one was like the the
epitome
of like people coming out screaming
trump was bad
and man you know i couldn't imagine this
the people who really believe the
mainstream press about trump
really do live in this psychotic
paranoid delusional state
this permanent perpetual paranoid
delusion
where donald trump is literally hitler
and
and all this crazy stuff's happening
it's just not true the worst thing about
it is if you see the coverage coming out
of
the new york times or the different
reporters who are based in new york i
mean donald trump has been a new york
figure
for five decades right all these people
have heard of donald trump
they all know who donald trump is now
there's lots of things that you can say
about donald trump
you don't like his attitude you don't
like his policies you don't like the way
he looks you don't like how he
appears so much in the press but all the
different things they were saying about
him you're right
fascists nazis stuff like he's like all
of these people
saw donald trump on tv they saw donald
trump at trump tower
they saw donald trump in new york
restaurants for decades and they turn
around and start saying this
stuff absolute nonsense they know better
that's the issue they all love right
exactly
and they sold this to the american
public and helped drive the american
public
crazy or at least half of it for a
combination of
money and virtue signaling kicks
oligarchical power they're they're
consolidating their power i mean i mean
kind of but you know
brian stelter is going to be living in a
shoe box if this if this country falls
apart he's
he's of uh of no societal value i mean
the dude probably can't even lift a
heavy bag to help someone load their
luggage into a car
i i'm not trying to be like overtly
disrespectful i mean quite literally
what would a man like brian selter do
were it not him running a propaganda you
know state tv
for the white house this is this is
fascinating because that's the way that
i see the press the press is the
courtier class right
this is what they are if we're looking
at the oligarchs you have
this is their ra these are the retainers
these are the people who work and don't
you like what monsieur has said
don't you like with the the the new pro
the new application
that monsieur has designed aren't you
interested in the new show that monsieur
has produced
that's what they are the retainers these
are people who
are uh their jobs are about messaging
on behalf of the oligarchs it reminds me
of that
episode of simpsons where mr burns is
fleeing to his escape pod
i forgot why and then you know smithers
tries to go with him he's like oh sorry
there's no room for you and then it like
launches them in there
uh they're they're the the weak little
uh
betas who will say anything and
everything
for the corrupt elites who are
extracting the resources from this
country
but when all said and done and the
country falls apart like they're
the first in line for whatever bad is is
going to be coming
they provide little of if anything in
terms of value to society
i mean these are people who who live in
new york city
who live in giant concrete cubicles who
espouse propaganda for the state
when the state has lost confidence to
the people because the elites have
extracted too much and now the system
topples
where do they go they have what what
reasonable skills do they have hey dylan
radigan went started hydra
doing hydroponics that guy was smart 10
years ago he's like i'm out i'm not
going to be playing that game
that guy's awesome yeah i mean if you
look
if you look at the history of these
different if we think
that this country is heading toward a
very dangerous very dark place
it may be it may not be but
regardless if you look at the history of
things that go bad
if you look at the history of
authoritarian states how these things
begin the bad things that happen
right it's a mistake for the ideological
class
for the ideologues they're always
they're always caught in the middle of
it yeah it's very it's very bad idea
well i just think that uh the nature of
america
as you mentioned stubbornness it's a lot
of defiance
it's not going to go the same as say
russia would or many of these european
nations would
um it'll be different call it a civil
war call whatever you want
you know i i we mentioned this quite a
bit in the context of it but um
there's a dividing line forming between
these states which you mentioned with
the vaccine segregation and the
passports
which lends itself to the idea that
if joe biden and the democrats keep
extracting and destroying this country
at what point will the republicans cut
things off and how will they do it
maybe texas announces a texas coin a
cryptocurrency for the people of texas a
local currency to protect the value
they you know look texas could florida
would probably do it first to be honest
because you got desantis
he'd probably launch and they just had
the bitcoin conference in miami right
think about this florida could launch as
a governmental entity
a d5 coin florida florida coin
that is legal tender in the state of
florida and what are the feds going to
do i mean i'm sure they would freak out
we'd buy a bunch of it
maybe the the issue is so long as the
fed can print money and biden can hand
it
for free to cuomo and to newsom to
whitmer
they when they spend money and destroy
things they are extracting the wealth
from the people of texas in florida
and and the other states utah idaho et
cetera productive states
that's right i'm thinking about i'm
still thinking about the greco uh the
greek
democracy this is so it's so parallel
they say history rhymes not necessarily
in repetition so what happened was
they they they defaulted on their tax
debt was the first thing they did
to get out of this problem uh the second
thing was
uh that they freed their slaves okay so
we're not in a state of slavery right
now although you could argue that we're
in fiscal slavery
student loan debt student loan debt
abolishing uh and so but what happened
was then the poor people came up and
they want they started to demand the
rich people's property
and the guy that had been put in charge
this guy named solon was this
brilliant you know merchant uh guy he
wasn't a landowner but he was just this
really really smart guy
said no we're not gonna strip the wealth
from the rich so
it's gonna happen again probably it's
likely that people are going to start
demanding we strip the wealth
what we see now that's different is the
mass printing of money
they didn't have that in ancient greece
they didn't have this money printer this
federal reserve
system this fiat so i don't know how
other than establishing a new currency
and issuing a debt recall and voiding
like the value of the dollar over like
the two year period this is why bitcoin
is key and why i'm so bullish on bitcoin
i'm not telling anybody else what to do
but we talk about how i mean you really
got to understand this
that the the blue states were in serious
trouble
before the pandemic their debts were
piling up we had in new york city they
want to do the amazon headquarters aoc
comes in starts spitting and yelling
and then amazon pulls out costing them
30 billion or more over a 10-year period
they need that money to fix the mta so
they're in serious trouble well don't
worry
don't worry you see donald trump said he
wasn't going to give a bailout
fortunately for them joe biden wins
joe biden gives them all the cash they
need now they got some cash reserves
but that that is causing hyperinflation
or i should say hyperinflation is
causing inflation
it's really high depending on who you
ask that means for someone in
texas who wants to buy a computer your
your ability to buy these goods has been
taken from you
by the corruption of andrew cuomo
how long will they stand for this i
don't know they might just be like okay
whatever
fine whatever and the federal government
gives grants and loans to many of these
states anyway many red states are
getting money from the government
so they'll probably just say sure fine
whatever but it is the savings
of the people in these places that are
being devalued and the governments
that are benefiting from it right it's
terrible i guess one
question is uh one question is how long
what's what's going to make people
change what's going to break them take
their food what will it be
yeah so long as they have food people
will probably do nothing
so it's kind of it so this is this is
i'll give you is my advice to the desk
bits you just got to go slow
you can't you can't you can't throw
boiling water on a frog
you got to put the frog in the pot and
boil the water that's how it's done
otherwise they freak out right make sure
their food costs don't go
too high you got to keep it below around
40 of their income per week otherwise
they snap you're right i was watching
this video last night about the hunter
gatherers i think it's the
um it starts with an h the hanzo hansa
it's the last hunter-gatherer tribe in
the world in like eastern africa and
this guy goes there and hunts with them
and they asked one of the hunters what's
the most important thing
in on earth like what is it what's the
greatest thing and he without even
thinking he said meat
and he's a hunter so he thinks meat but
it's food it's food right we think about
all these lofty ideals and
ways and love and it's it's food
you need food to live bro dude it's all
about the water water and food because
if you don't have water you're gonna
the food will kill you if these
shortages get
worse i mean all you need only look at
uh these photos of shopping
shopping markets during hurricanes all
the meat is gone yeah
the vegan section's fine though people
don't want to eat bugs
and they'll they'll try eat the bugs
come on you eat because we're going to
have steak we're going to have fancy
steaks you guys eat the bugs though
take their food away be happy but there
is a way out
there is and it's i i would i don't know
the regulations or the laws on this
but it would be really amazing if uh
texas just said hey we're making taxes
coin
that'd be awesome every state should
have their own i mean it used to be that
way the states used to have their own
currency
you can go online it's amazing i went to
uh one website where they sell rhode
island dollars yeah like
legal tender in the state of rhode
island rhode island early on nowhere
else
is it just a one for one to the dollar i
mean i guess another thing that would be
interesting is if you look at you know
people
i i don't know if it's still there after
after kova but people have spoken about
california has the world's third largest
economy so
what about texas what about florida it
seems that florida is particularly
california's economy is enormous because
of its trade with asia especially with
china
right but if you look at the other if
you look at texas and florida
these states are also well disposed to
uh
trade as well so what are the different
ways for
what are the different ways for red
states to build there
to build there to build their economics
think about things
again i i'm willing to bet the feds
would storm in two seconds with guns if
any state tried to do this
but imagine if texas said okay is what
we're doing as the government we're
going to be issuing a cryptocurrency
called texas coin where we'll print 21
million over the span of 100 years
and um it's it's mined or whatever
however
if you are a resident of the state of
texas
or a registered business and you're
representative of that business you can
exchange your texas coin for us dollar
which means in in in the texas economy
they back their currency
no that wouldn't work that wouldn't work
because inflation would still hit them
but imagine they said oh no no they
could
it would it would just there would be an
exchange rate between the dollar and the
texas coin
then the texas coin is is deflationary
so if you have
if you live in texas and you choose to
accept texas currency
its value goes up while the dollar goes
down people in texas are going to be
like i don't want to use dollar
anymore and if you ever need to you can
just go to the government and as a
resident do an exchange
do you think this is i mean are people
talking about this
no no no no i'm not i just they just
came in my all right thought of it
i'm sure some people are it's really
interesting i mean florida
look i don't even think the government
needs to do it if the government backed
it
or if anyone created a reserve and said
you know
it's it's imagine this right there's a
lot of cryptocurrencies
each and every one can be exchanged for
some monetary value for the most part
some
don't some are private utility tokens
but uh let's say like you know dogecoin
right now is at like 35 cents or
something
what if you the only way to actually do
an exchange it was only
it was only available to the people of
the state of florida now if you live in
texas you can have some
and you can trade it with people in
florida but you can't get dollars out of
it unless you're a resident
then the residents would be like oh we
want to accept this because we can use
it amongst ourselves
retains its value becomes more valuable
so if someone pays me
one florida coin and i put in the bank
in a month
it's basically basically worth two
florida coin i'm not taking those
dollars i'm taking
the florida backed crypto and then the
value
it costs when it starts it's one to one
one dollar is one florida coin
a month later two dollars is one florida
coin because of it wouldn't be that
dramatic but inflation five percent
you could always just exchange it back
for us dollars it would be like
literally any other cryptocurrency
the difference is the lo the state
government of florida or texas or
whatever state or maybe new york would
do it are
putting regulation on it statewide which
provides incentive for me
for people in that state to use it and
doesn't allow exchange for dollars
outside of the state don't now however
people could still trade off market
right someone would be like hey i'll
give you texas coin for dollars or
whatever
and you could do that anywhere you could
have it do discounts too locally like if
you spend new york coin in new york you
get a
one percent discount on anything you buy
it would be easy to tax
the government could have fees on every
transaction instantly
taxed do we have a sense like how
different the
difference between the trump
administration and the biden
administration on cryptocurrency
is there a big difference trump really
yeah i don't i don't know
what biden's position position's been i
mean they're trying to regulate it trump
called it a scam
he's wrong but uh it seems like the
federal government really does not like
it
state street's going in hard on crypto
right now they're the second i think
it's the second
second or third largest investment firm
in the world alongside blackrock and
uh and vanguard but state street if you
look up state street news
yesterday uh they're launching a
cryptocurrency division
so to me bitcoin is a savings account
if you put your money in a bank it's
gonna it's it's dry it's losing value
every day
you put in bitcoin it's gaining value
every day i don't care what they say
when that when when
and again i'm not telling anybody to buy
anything no financial advice for me
what i'm saying is bitcoin based on
the function of it the capitalization
the liquidity
the everything it's it's going up in
value
now in the short term you can see
volatility but you ignore that stuff
i don't care if bitcoin dropped to 10
bucks right now i'd panic buy as much as
possible
like wow yeah go nuts i just buy as much
as i could
but i don't think people i mean people
where is it right now
um i think it's a 36 maybe 35. it was at
37 earlier there's a 32 the other day
like if you're day trading you're
probably making a killing yeah you check
it out all the time
i mean are you sometimes i forget that
sort of three days sort of um
my i've always just been someone who's
bought and then ignored it because it's
a savings account
i was day trading for a while you can
make a lot of money if you're day
trading i mean you can make like two to
seven percent
daily it's crazy how much money you can
make per day
and if you're moving ten million dollars
a day you know that's 770 grand and just
like
look it hit 65k and
then it dropped to 30 or whatever and it
was mostly poor people who panicked and
sold off and all the rich people were
laughing the whole time
because the rich people aren't worried
about short-term losses like this
it's like dude if i buy one bitcoin one
bitcoin equals one bitcoin
but if you're poor and you put in your
only 200 hoping to turn it into 400 and
then the market tanks you panic and pull
it out you've lost your money
you just you you buy when you can you
know for me i'll buy
when i can i forget about it something
ron paul was talking about a lot was
getting rid of this
law that says that the u.s government or
congress has the monopoly on
on a currency control of currency
creation basically which they've
already offloaded to the federal reserve
anyway so they're basically they've
they've given up their
their responsibility to some private
quasi-private public company
um and ron i don't know what the exact
law is dave smith was talking about when
he was on the show but ron paul's been
we need to we need to repeal or remove
that restriction so that we can all
legally create our own
and create a market of currency market
because the u.s dollar
can't carry the load it it's up we've
see where we're watching it happen
i i would rather own um
rocks like i'd rather buy a bag of
gravel
than have a us dollar right now i wonder
what the value of that's increased by
travel's going to go up it's it's going
to become more and more expensive
yeah you're right timber right
absolutely so we we we got these parks
built here
and it's it's too these days we couldn't
get it done it's too expensive but the
best thing is
they had leftover oddly shaped you know
lumber here and there and boards because
they cut things and they say here's the
waste
and the guy i remember when they were
building they were like so we'll have
this all hauled away and i was like no
no
no at the time i was like just throw it
in the shed because we like building
stuff
i'm sure we'll build something we built
some like pvc rails like for you know
skating and stuff and now we have this
shed full of wood
and i'm like wow thousands and thousands
of dollars no joke
at the time it was probably a total of
like a thousand dollars worth of
materials
a year ago and it's probably worth like
seven or eight thousand now
some ridiculous amount of money for all
these materials plus there's just like
um there's like steel bars and and pipes
and stuff that you use for for you know
skating on
so wow i'm like we could probably do a
sale on this make a ton of money right
now
no but i want it because we want to
build stuff and go in the construction
company and
uh yeah i would rather have a bag of of
rocks
no joke because sourcing the rocks is
hard sourcing the dollar is nothing joe
biden's just making it rain on everybody
and i'm like there's no scarcity to the
dollar someone's got to go and get those
rocks
that's got value you know that's
interesting that's a great sales pitch
that's fantastic i'm holding a bag of
gravel i'm holding the bag right here
yeah i'm holding a bag of rocks
but i'm not even i'm not i'm being
serious no i know i i know it sounds if
somebody sounds great if somebody came
with like a home depot
like you know gray gravel for the
driveway i'd be like how much
i'd love ten bucks i'd be like done i'd
love to see an alec baldwin version of
this like glenn gary glenn ross
you walk into the room you're holding a
bag of rocks just like that i'm going to
buy some rocks
always be selling all weeds always be
selling
babies always be closing abc always be
closing that's glengarry
and you're holding the bag of rocks yeah
the problem is where would you store the
rocks
hence we created currency to you know
stand in for the plates the rocks don't
the rocks deflate
well i guess the rocks inflate value but
the dollars
become worthless so buy the rocks now
for 10 bucks and then in a month it'll
be worth 12 bucks yeah
that's no joke dude yeah it takes a lot
of effort to grind up that gravel and
move it around you know
what's like the most worst worthless
thing you can imagine i mean look
things you normally would think are
worthless that people wouldn't want to
have wood glass you know you know back
at the other other house where we had
the studio
we had a bunch of wood a bunch of wood
that we just bought
because it was cheap and we were using
it to build stuff we just left it we
didn't care
that's probably a couple hundred bucks
right now that we just left behind that
was only like 20 bucks when we bought it
i mean i'm getting bookcases made i i
know
i know what it looks like i know how
much more it is now than it was uh than
it was a year ago
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you